and as for Hoda we know a lot of you
have been wondering how she's doing we
can tell you that Hoda's okay Hoda
copy's absence from The Today Show
finally explained the NBC morning show
co-anchor hasn't appeared on TV in more
than a week and on Wednesday we learned
why Craig Melvin alongside Chanel Jones
uh in for Savannah and Hoda who are both
out this morning they'll be back soon
but we're actually going to have a
little more on that coming up Craig
Melvin and Chanel Jones manned the desk
at the top of the show and shared that
both Hoda and Savannah Guthrie were out
but would be back soon Savannah she is
at home after a positive covet test
yesterday we are wishing our friend a
speedy recovery and as for Hoda we know
a lot of you have been wondering how
she's doing we can tell you that Hoda's
okay she's got a family health matter
that she has been dealing with so we
look forward to seeing Hoda and Savannah
back here at the desk very very soon
Savannah appeared on Tuesday's episode
of today but shortly after the show
started she was noticeably absent and it
was later revealed she tested positive
for covid Savannah left early she wasn't
feeling great so she took a covet test
it came back positive so of course as
soon as we found out she rushed home to
rest up so Savannah we love you wishing
you a speeding well Chanel was sitting
between me and uh
as for Hoda her last live appearance on
the show was February 17th yay for
Friday and yay for this long holiday
weekend it's arriving right on time
World News Tonight anger Tom yamas and
today third hour co-host Craig Melvin
have been subbing for Hoda over the last
week alongside Savannah meanwhile Willie
Geist from Sunday today and Chanel Jones
of today third hour have filled in
alongside Jenna Bush Hager for Hoda's
fourth hour gig Chanel is here for Hoda
happy Monday happy Monday Whitley Geist
is in for Hoda good to see you again you
know what I'm happy you're here this is
great and while Hoda hasn't been on the
show she has been on social media
posting some inspirational quotes and
messages on her Instagram which is
pretty typical for the mom of two
earlier this week Hoda shared this image
with the quote choose hope some days I
feel powerful most things I feel
vulnerable and while Hoda is temporarily
out there's no doubt her colleagues feel
her absence we know how blessed we are
we know how lucky we are earlier this
month Savannah told E.T Hoda's a pretty
big deal in her book I mean Hoda at the
top of the list always she she's an icon
I mean she absolutely is just one of
just a rock to me and to all of us every
single day
[Music]
thank you